[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] >>
Jon: WELCOME BACK. MY GUEST
TONIGHT, HE'S THE HOST OF "THE
O'REILLY FACTOR" ON THE
FOX NEWS PROGRAM CHANNEL. HIS
NEW BOOK IS "KILLING PATTON:
THE STRANGE DEATH OF WORLD
WAR II'S MOST AUDACIOUS
GENERAL."
PLEASE WELCOME BACK TO OUR
PROGRAM, MR. WILLIAM O'REILLY.
WILLIAM! HELLO, WILLIAM? NICE TO
SEE YOU, SIR.
[APPLAUSE]
HAVE A SEAT.
I'M GLAD, GIVEN THE EBOLA SCARE,
YOU STILL ARE SHAKING MY HAND.
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK THAT'S A POSITIVE STEP.
I KNOW YOU'RE VERY FRIGHTENED
AND I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU
EVERYTHING'S GOING TO BE OKAY.
THERE YOU GO, BABY.
[LAUGHTER]
GET THAT GOING.
SETTLE DOWN.
[LAUGHTER]
THE BOOK IS CALLED BILL O'REILLY
"KILLING PATTON," IT'S LIKE WHAT
LIKE THE EIGTH.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO CALL THIS
SERIES KILLING TREES.
THE SELL LIKE CRAZY.
>> YOU DIDN'T READ IT, THOUGH.
>> Jon: NO, I DID NOT READ
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M GOING TO WAIT FOR THE
LIFETIME SERIES.
>> BUT I WANT YOU TO DIRECT IT.
>> Jon: I WILL DIRECT IT.
>> I WANT YOU TO DIRECT IT.
>> I'D BE HAPPY TO DIRECT
IT.
>> I KNOW YOU WOULD.
>> Jon: I'M A DIRECTOR NOW.
>> I KNOW. YOU HAVE A VAMPIRE
MOVIE COMING OUT.
>> Jon: SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S ONE OF THEM TWEEN MOVIES.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: WHERE LOVE IS FOUND
UNEXPECTEDLY.
>> THAT'S THE THEME OF "KILLING
PATTON."
>> Jon: NO IT'S NOT. HERE'S WHAT
I LOVE ABOUT THIS.
LOOK AT THE COVER OF THERE. IT'S
JUST LIKE, PATTON'S JUST SITTING
THERE AND HITLER'S JUST GIVING
HIM THE EYEBALLS.
LOOK AT THAT. LOOK AT HITLER.
OH, I'M GOING TO GET YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
LISTEN TO ME.
>> YEP.
>> Jon: HERE'S ALL I WANT FROM
YOU TODAY.
>> UH HUH.
>> Jon: THIS IS IT.
>> YEP.
>> Jon: THIS IS ALL WE'VE GOT TO
DO IN THIS CONVERSATION.
>> OKAY.
>> Jon: JUST ONE, I HAVE
ONE SIMPLE GOAL.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: I WANT YOU TO ADMIT THAT
THERE IS SUCH A THING AS WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
THAT'S ALL I WANT.
>> I KNEW YOU WERE GOING THERE.
[CROWD CHEERING]
>> Jon: THAT'S ALL I WANT.
THAT'S IT. JUST A LITTLE, I JUST
WANT YOU TO SAY, I'M TERRIBLY
TERRIBLY WRONG ON THIS.
I JUST WANT YOU TO LOOK IN --
>> IN YOUR CASE, THERE IS WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
>> Jon: THANK YOU.
>> THE FACT THAT YOU'RE HERE
SITTING THERE.
>> Jon: THANK YOU.
>> HE DOESN'T EVEN SHAVE.
>> Jon: WHAT?
>> HE DOESN'T EVEN -- LOOK AT
YOU.
>> Jon: WHAT? I SHAVE.
>> WHAT -- THERE ISN'T -- YOU
DIDN'T SHAVE.
>> Jon: THIS GROWTH IS FROM
-- IT'S CALLED JEWISH PRIVILEGE,
IT HAPPENS. WE ARE A
HIRSUTE PEOPLE.
>> OH.
>> Jon: YOU HAVE SAID, YOU'VE
STATED THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: THERE IS, I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A THING
CALLED WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> THERE IS NOT.
>> Jon: SEE NOW, OKAY, NOW WE
HAVE A CONVERSATION WE CAN HAVE.
>> OKAY, LOOK IF THERE'S WHITE
PRIVILEGE THEN THERE HAS TO BE
ASIAN PRIVILEGE.
>> Jon: WHAT?
>> BECAUSE ASIANS MAKE MORE
MONEY THAN WHITES.
>> Jon: WHAT.
>> OH, YOU DIDN'T KNOW ANY OF
THIS, HUH?
>> Jon: WELL NOT, NOT, WHAT KIND
OF ASIAN? YOU HAVE TO SPECIFY.
>> ASIAN AMERICANS. ASIAN
AMERICANS.
>> Jon: WELL NO, IT DEPENDS ON
WHERE THEY'RE FROM, IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT --
>> THEY'RE FROM ASIA.
THEY'RE ASIAN AMERICANS.
>> Jon: I UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> GOOD.
>> Jon: BUT AS A --
>> THEY MAKE MORE MONEY,
HIGHER EDUCATION, MORE AFFLUENT.
SO IT'S ASIAN PRIVILEGE, NOT
WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> YOU'RE MISSING THE POINT.
AND, AND, AND THE POINT --
>> OH, SORRY TO CONFUSE YOU WITH
FACTS.
>> YOU'RE NOT, IT'S NOT
THE -- THAT'S, OKAY, HERE WE GO.
THE ASIAN EXPERIENCE IN AMERICA,
THE ASIAN IMMIGRANT EXPERIENCE.
>> YES.
>> Jon: IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
THE BLACK EXPERIENCE.
>> YES.
>> SO IT'S REALLY, THEY'RE NOT
EQUIVALENT.
AND EITHER WAY, WHITE PEOPLE,
MALES, SET THE SYSTEM, SO THAT'S
WHAT PRIVILEGE IS, IS THAT WHITE
PEOPLE SET THE SYSTEM THAT
YES, MAYBE ASIAN IMMIGRANTS ONCE
IMMIGRATION POLICIES WERE
LIBERALIZED HAVE DONE BETTER
OVER THESE PAST 30 OR 40 YEARS.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN A SYSTEMIC,
SYSTEMIC SYSTEMATIZED
SUBJUGATION OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
WOULD YOU NOT AGREE WITH THAT?
>> SURE. I MEAN, EVERYBODY
KNOWS --
>> WELL THEN THAT'S IT, THAT'S
WHITE PRIVILEGE.
YOU JUST DID IT. YOU JUST DID
IT.
THAT'S ALL, THAT'S ALL THIS IS.
>> WHAT HAPPENS TO THAT HAND
SANITIZER. YOU WANT SOME?
>> ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S ALL THIS IS.
>> LOOK, THAT WAS
THEN. THIS IS NOW.
>> Jon: OH IT'S, THERE
WAS WHITE PRIVILEGE
BUT IT NO LONGER EXISTS.
>> WAIT WAIT, MAYBE YOU HAVEN'T
FIGURED OUT THAT THERE IS
NO MORE SLAVERY, NO MORE JIM
CROW, ALL RIGHT?
>> Jon: OH, ALRIGHT, ALRIGHT.
>> AND THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN
THE WORLD.
>> Jon: ALRIGHT. OH BOY, HERE WE
GO.
>> IS A BLACK AMERICAN.
>> Jon: OH BOY.
>> AND THE MOST POWERFUL
WOMAN IN THE WORLD,
OPRAH WINFREY IS BLACK. OKAY?
>> Jon: BEING ABLE TO GIVE
PEOPLE A FREE CAR DOES NOT MAKE
YOU THE MOST POWERFUL
WOMAN IN THE WORLD.
>> THIS IS, THIS IS.
>> Jon: BUT LISTEN, BUT LISTEN
CLOSE -- BECAUSE I SEE --
>> DON'T MESS WITH.
>> Jon: NO, NO, NO. I SEE --
>> SHE'LL COME IN HERE AND SHAVE
YOU.
>> Jon: I SEE THE ISSUE HERE.
YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
RESIDUAL EFFECT OF,
I MEAN SLAVERY AND JIM CROW ARE
DEAD BUT THE RESIDUAL EFFECTS
OF THAT SYSTEM SUBJUGTION EXISTS
TODAY.
>> SURE. IT ABSOLUTELY EXISTS
>> Jon: LET'S GO A DIFFERENT
WAY.
>> IT EXISTS FOR EVERY RACE,
NOT AT THAT EXTENT, ALL RIGHT?
>> Jon: SO THAT'S WHITE
PRIVILEGE. OH BOY.
>> BUT YOU DON'T PUT FORTH,
ALL RIGHT, THIS OH,
WHITE PRIVILEGE AND IF YOU FAIL
THAT'S WHY YOU FAIL, ALL RIGHT.
AMERICA'S NOW A PLACE...
>> Jon: OKAY.
>> WHERE IF YOU WORK HARD AND
GET EDUCATED AND YOU'RE
AN HONEST PERSON, YOU CAN
SUCCEED.
THAT WHAT SHOULD BE PUT OUT
THERE.
NOT ALL THIS OTHER STUFF.
>> Jon: YOU ARE CARRYING, YOU
ARE CARRYING, YOU ARE CARRYING
MORE OF THE BURDEN AS A BLACK
PERSON IN THIS
COUNTRY THAN A WHITE PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY. FROM EVEN --
>> COLLECTIVELY, YES, BUT NOT --
>> Jon: NO, INDIVIDUALLY.
>> LISTEN. INDIVIDUALLY EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE IS DIFFERENT.
>> Jon: THEY DON'T STOP AT EVERY
AND FRISK WALL STREET BANKERS --
EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE DONE FAR
MORE DAMAGE TO THE ECONOMY.
>> THEY DON'T STOP AND FRISK
WALL STREET BANKERS.
>> WHITE PEOPLE, LISTEN TO ME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WHITE PEOPLE DO MORE DRUGS
IN THIS COUNTRY THAN BLACK
PEOPLE --
>> YES.
>> Jon: BUT BLACK PEOPLE MAKE
UP A FAR HIGHER MAJORITY OF DRUG
ARRESTS.
>> YOU DO KNOW WHY THAT
IS?
>> Jon: YES.
>> YOU DO KNOW WHY THAT IS. WHY
IS THAT?
>> Jon: BECAUSE BLACK PEOPLE,
IT'S ABOUT REAL ESTATE TO SOME
EXTENT. THERE HAS BEEN A
SYSTEMIC SUBJUGATION THROUGH
REAL ESTATE, BLACK PEOPLE
ARE GHETTOIZED IN THIS COUNTRY,
AND THOSE GHETTOS --
>> THEY'RE FORCED TO LIVE
THERE, THEY HAVE TO LIVE THERE
IS WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME?
>> Jon: OH YOU'RE GETTING TO A
BAD PLACE, MY FRIEND.
>> LISTEN, THIS IS THE
USUAL WHITE GUILT, LIBERAL STUFF
>> Jon: THIS IS NOT GUILT. THIS
IS FACT.
>> YOU GUYS THROW OUT --
>> Jon: I DON'T FEEL GUILTY.
>> YOU SHOULD.
>> Jon: WHY?
>> YOU'RE GETTING PAID FOR
THIS.
>> Jon: OH WHAT, YOU MEAN FOR
THIS. OKAY, LET'S GO BACK HERE.
>> YEAH, YOU SHOULD FEEL VERY
GUILTY.
>> Jon: WHAT MADE YOU
CULTURALLY?
>> LOOK, THIS IS THE USUAL
STUFF.
>> NO, NO, NO, WHAT MADE YOU
CULTURALLY? DO YOU THINK YOUR UP
BRINGING GAVE YOU
VALUES, ETHICS.
>> YES. YES IT DID.
>> Jon: YOU DIDN'T GROW UP RICH,
RIGHT?
>> NO. WE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH MONEY
AT ALL.
>> Jon: BUT YOU WORKED HARD.
>> I DID.
>> Jon: RIGHT. YOU WORKED HARD.
>> RIGHT.
>> Jon: YOU LIVED WHERE.
>> LEVITTOWN
>> Jon: LEVITTOWN.
>> NEW YORK.
>> Jon: SO IT GAVE YOU A NICE
STABLE, A CHEAP HOME, THERE WERE
NO DOWN PAYMENTS.
THERE WAS THIS INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY.
NO, THOSE HOUSES WERE
SUBSIDIZED.
>> OH IT WAS LAVISH.
>> Jon: NO, IT WASN'T LAVISH.
BUT IT WAS STABLE.
>> NO, THEY WEREN'T SUBSIDIZED.
>> Jon: BUT IT WAS STABLE.
>> THEY WERE SOLD TO GI'S AND
THE GI'S GOT A MORTGAGE THEY
COULD AFFORD. LOOK --
>> Jon: BUT LET ME JUST ASK YOU
A QUESTION.
>> YOU'RE MAKING A HUGE MISTAKE.
>> Jon: NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. LET
ME JUST ASK YOU A QUESTION.
>> YEs.
>> Jon: DID THAT UP BRINGING
LEAVE A MARK ON YOU EVEN TODAY?
>> OF COURSE.
EVERY UP BRINGING LEAVES A MARK
ON PEOPLE.
>> Jon: GREAT. GREAT. COULD
BLACK PEOPLE LIVE IN LEVITTTOWN?
>> NOT AT THAT TIME, THEY COULD
NOT.
>> SO THAT MY FRIEND IS WHAT WE
CALL IN THE BUSINESS WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
>> MY FRIEND. OKAY.
[APPLAUSE]
THAT WAS IN -- NO, THAT WAS
IN 1950, ALL RIGHT.
1950.
>> WERE THERE BLACK PEOPLE
LIVING THERE IN 1960.
>> IN LEVITTTOWN?
>> Jon: YES.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jon: THEY WEREN'T.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW.
>> BECAUSE I READ UP ON IT.
>> OH YOU READ UP.
YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> Jon: YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> I COULD FIND SOMEBODY.
>> MY POINT IS THIS, EVEN
TODAY --
>> WHY WOULD YOU WANT
TO LIVE THERE.
IT'S A NICE PLACE, BUT IT'S NOT
A PLACE LIKE YOU,
IT'S NOT LIKE BEL AIR, COME ON.
>> BECAUSE IT'S A PLACE THAT
BUILT VALUES.
WHAT YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND IS
IMAGINE GROWING UP --
>> THERE ARE MILLIONS OF BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT BUILD VALUES.
MILLIONS OF THEM.
>> Jon: BUT IMAGINE GROWING UP
KNOWING THAT YOU AS AN AMERICAN.
>> YEAH.
>> AS A GI WHO FOUGHT
IN WORLD WAR II.
>> YEAH.
>> COULDN'T BUY INTO THAT
BECAUSE YOU WERE LESS.
>> IT WAS UNFAIR, IT WAS
UNFAIR.
>> Jon: AND THE RESIDUE OF THAT
CONTINUES TODAY.
>> THE RESIDUE.
>> Jon: AND THAT IS WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
> IF YOU WANT TO SAY IT'S WHITE
PRIVILEGE --
>> Jon: I'M NOT SAYING IT'S AN
EXCUSE. I'M SAYING IT EXISTS.
>> BECAUSE WHITES DIDN'T HAVE IT
AS BAD AS BLACKS. FINE.
>> Jon: THAT'S IT.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE IN CONTEMPORARY SOCIETY.
>> YES, IT IS.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
LET ME REPEAT THIS AND I'LL DO
IT SLOWLY.
>> Jon: ALRIGHT.
>> SO EVEN YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
IT.
>> ALRIGHT. ALRIGHT.
>> IF YOU WORK HARD, IF YOU GET
EDUCATED, IF YOU'RE AN HONEST
PERSON, YOU CAN MAKE IT IN
AMERICA.
>> IF YOU LIVE IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE PEOPLE ARE, POVERTY IS
ENDEMIC.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: IT'S HARDER
TO WORK HARD.
IT'S HARDER TO GET AN EDUCATION.
>> IT'S HARDER -- HEY, IT WAS
HARDER FOR ME THAN THE WHITE GUY
IN GARDEN CITY.
IT'S ALL RELATIVE.
YES, IT'S HARDER IF YOU'RE A
GHETTO KID.
YES.
BUT CAN YOU DO IT? YES.
>> Jon: YES YOU CAN.
>> YOU CAN ALSO WIN THE HUNDRED
YARD DASH ON ONE LEG.
>> OH STOP.
>> Jon: BUT IT'S HARDER.
>> JUST STOP. ALRIGHT.
>> IT'S JUST -- ALL I'M ASKING
IS THIS. HERE'S ALL I'M ASKING.
>> YES.
>> Jon: HERE'S ALL I'M ASKING
BECAUSE THIS WOULD, I THINK, GO
A LONG WAY WHAT'S A HUGE RACIAL
ISSUE IN OUR COUNTRY.
JUST AN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THAT.
NO BODY'S BLAMING YOU --
>> EVERY FAIR PERSON
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT, AND
I'VE SAID
IT MANY TIMES ON THE FACTOR, THE
HIGHEST RATED CABLE NEWS SHOW
IN THE WORLD, ALRIGHT.
>> Jon: OH JESUS.
>> THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE
IT HARDER.
>> Jon: SOMEBODY HASN'T SEEN
MEGYN KELLY YET.
>> OH.
>> Jon: SHE'S CRUSHING YOU,
DUDE. SHE'S CRUSHING YOU.
>> NOW YOU'RE YOU'RE MISLEADING
THIS AUDIENCE.
>> Jon: SHE'S CRUSHING YOU.
>> YOU'RE MISLEADING.
>> Jon: ALRIGHT. ALL I'M SAYING
IS --
>> DO YOU HAVE THE SANITIZER
AGAIN.
>> YES. YOU ADMIT.
SO, HERE'S MY POINT.
SO, WE'VE COME TO AGREEMENT.
YOU ADMIT THAT WHITE PRIVILEGE
EXISTS AND WHILE IT'S NOT AN
EXCUSE, IT'S A REALITY.
>> IT DOESN'T EXIST TO ANY
EXTENT WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE
KEPT BACK BECAUSE OF THEIR COLOR
OR PROMOTED BECAUSE OF THEIR
COLOR.
LOOK YOU AND I ARE LUCKY GUYS.
WE MADE IT, WE WORKED HARD.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE WE'RE WHITE.
>> Jon: WAIT, WAIT. WELL --
>> OH, YOU THINK I'M SITTING
HERE BECAUSE I'M WHITE.
WHAT ARE YOU A MORON.
[AUDIENCE REACTS]
I'M SITTING HERE BECAUSE I'M
OBNOXIOUS, NOT BECAUSE I'M
WHITE.
>> NO, LISTEN TO ME. THE POINT
IS THIS.
WHEN YOU, WHEN YOU TRY AND
REDUCE IT TO BEING SOLELY ABOUT
THAT, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT MY POINT IS THIS.
WOMEN FACE THIS AND MINORITIES
FACE IT.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE STRATEGIC
CALCULATIONS IN THEIR LIVES THAT
WHITE GUYS NEVER HAVE TO MAKE.
>> YEAH.
>> WE NEVER HAVE TO, WE NEVER
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WALKING DOWN CERTAIN STREETS
BECAUSE SOMEBODY'S GOING TO CAT
CALL US.
WE NEVER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IF
WHEN WE MOVE INTO A NEIGHBORHOOD
WE'RE GOING TO BE ACCEPTED,
THESE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> MAYBE YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT IT, I DID.
IF I HAD TO MOVE INTO A
NEIGHBORHOOD TO BE ACCEPTED.
I WASN'T ACCEPTED ANYWHERE. LOOK
YOU'RE GENERALIZING.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> AND YOU'RE, WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS YOU'RE PROMOTING VICTIMHOOD.
>> Jon: NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
>> YES, YES, YES, YES, YES.
>> Jon: ALRIGHT. WHAT YOU CALL
VICTIMHOOD, WHAT I'M SAYING IS
BY ACKNOWLEDGING THAT REALITY
THAT GOES A LONG WAY TOWARDS
HEALING THE RESENTMENT.
>> I ACKNOWLEDGE THE HISTORICAL
REALITY.
>> Jon: AND JUST, AND LET'S, SO
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS
WHY SO DEFENSIVE ABOUT IT?
WHY IS IT THAT WHITE PEOPLE GET
SO DEFENSIVE ABOUT THIS?
I'M NOT SAYING THAT LIFE ISN'T
HARD.
MIDDLE CLASS WHITE GUYS THAT
ARE WORKING HARD TO DO WHAT THEY
CAN AND LOOK AND GO I'M NOT
GETTING ANY PRIVILEGE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS A
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
BROUGHT HERE.
THEY DIDN'T CHOOSE TO IMMIGRATE
HERE TO GET THAT BETTER LIFE.
AND JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR
COUNTRY'S HAD A PROBLEM WITH
THAT AND WE CAN MOVE --
>> PEOPLE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WHO
ARE FAIR MINDED.
BUT YOU DON'T THEN TAKE THAT AND
THEN CONDEMN THE MODERN SOCIETY
BECAUSE OF IT.
>> jon: NOBODY'S CONDEMNING.
>> YES YOU ARE.
IT'S WHITE PRIVILEGE THAT MAKES
YOU SUCCESSFUL.
I EVEN HEARD THAT OVER HERE.
>> IT'S JUST SAID THAT'S NOT.
>> YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE NOT A
WOMAN IT'S -- COME ON.
>> Jon: DO YOU KNOW WHAT I'LL
CALL IT, I'LL CALL IT THIS AND
IT'S A WORD I THINK
YOU'LL UNDERSTAND.
A FACTOR.
IT'S A FACTOR.
>> A FACTOR.
>> IT'S A FACTOR.
>> I'LL GIVE YOU THE FACTOR
BUSINESS.
>> YOU DID. YOU'RE
GIVING ME THE FACTOR.
COMMON CAUSE. THAT'S IT. THAT'S
ALL.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO WE'RE OKAY.
>> ARE WE ON THE AIR?
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE'VE BEEN ON THE AIR THE
WHOLE TIME. LET ME
TELL YOU SOMETHING.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: THIS WAS, THIS WAS A
BEAUTIFUL MOMENT IN
HEALING BETWEEN NOT JUST BLACK
AND WHITE, JEW AND IRISH,
TALL AND SHORT.
THIS WAS AN HISTORIC MOMENT.
>> YEAH. ARE YOU HAPPY NOW,
STEWART?
ARE YOU HAPPY?
>> HAPPINESS IS NOT WHAT COMES
BEHIND ME.
BUT LET ME SAY THIS.
YOUR HUMILITY HAS MOVED ME.
>> HA HA HA.
>> YOU ARE LIKE POPE FRANCIS
THAT HAS TAKEN THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH INTO AN ERA OF
ACCEPTANCE AND HUMILITY.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: YOU, YOU BILL O'REILLY
CAN LEAD THE FLOCK OF THE FOX
FEARFUL TO A BETTER PLACE.
[LAUGHTER]
I BELIEVE YOU IN.
[APPLAUSE]
THE BOOK IS CALLED "KILLING
PATTON," AND I'M SURE YOU'VE
SOLD A LOT.
>> NO WHITE PRIVILEGE IN THE
BOOK.
>> Jon: BILL O'REILLY, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN.
>> ALRIGHT.